foreign
[Music]
Chris yes Chris uh where'd you grow up
where are you from are you from a town
called Pensacola Florida
it's on the Panhandle right there by
Alabama yep uh I lived there for like 20
something years
and then I moved to Mississippi for like
eight years
and I was helping take care of my
grandpa and then he finally died and so
I moved to uh
I moved to I was gonna go to California
uh originally but then I had this weird
dream that it was like I got killed when
I went to California so I was just like
I'm not gonna go
and uh or the person I was gonna go with
couldn't go with me yeah
and
but I went on vacation with my boss to
Las Vegas we went on vacation to spread
his son's ashes and meet some family
friends of theirs and schizophrenia just
kicked it out of nowhere like I wasn't
on drugs I was just smoking weed and uh
I wasn't even drinking and just all of a
sudden I started hearing voices and
seeing things and I have these crazy
thoughts all the time
and it was it was schizophrenia yeah I
still deal with it now since uh it went
away for a little bit like when I was in
jail because uh
I was um
I'm not supposed to talk about it
because I talk about it it makes it go
away but if it's if I keep it around I'm
keeping somebody alive
I'm sorry
what
uh it's like I'm connected with another
extra like with an extra dimensional
being and I'm keeping it alive by
keeping certain aspects of what I see in
my psychosis it's like real [__] like
other people will respond to it in time
like in proper time sequence
and uh
if you talk about it if I talk about it
it goes away
so that's a good thing
no yeah unless it's real and then I'm
killing somebody
so so you ended up in jail yeah uh I
heard I heard this dude or it was like
10 guys raping a little girl
and uh I was gonna grab a break and rush
in the house and she was like she told
me psychically she's like don't do that
there's like 10 of them they'll just
kill you and continue to write me
do this light the house on fire and know
how when they go outside to put the fire
out I'll be able to escape and get out
so I did I left the house on fire and
they caught me they got me on camera was
there a girl in 10 guys no
no just schizophrenia that was your
schizophrenia yeah you ended up in jail
yeah for attempted murder
going to prison for arson oh prison for
yeah wow
it was all because of your schizophrenia
yeah I had uh I even had three doctors I
was fighting my case in GI which is not
guilty by insanity and I could have gone
to a mental hospital instead of prison
but they were like basically if you go
to the mental hospital you could spend
your whole life there
I was like okay just give me the four
years in prison
but now I gotta register as an arsonist
and all this other stuff
is there schizophrenia in your family no
that's the weird part my mom okay my mom
has cancer and when she went into
chemotherapy she went to psychosis for
like two weeks in during chemo where she
thought her her boyfriend wasn't real he
was a computer program and like uh
there's no way he was gonna come visit
her and stuff like that
mine is nothing like that mine is like
some Ninja [__]
I'm like a psychic wizard who can like
communicate with people using different
methods like there's voices on the cars
as they pass by you can hear them
talking through the cars or like on the
wind or like there'll be like certain
noises you'll hear like a knock of wood
on the right side at this time means
something like means yes or no you know
like binary and then there's then
there's like symbols in the sky with uh
like black and white balls of light and
they change direction and it looks like
a game of uh go
you're in your right mind now so no I've
been hearing voices since I got about
put back on the street I think it's a
stress
well I guess what I'm getting at is you
understand that you're imagining these
things yeah I'm taking my medication and
uh but it's even even the fact that you
understand it I try not to engage with
it yeah but like it seems like the more
I ignore it the worse it gets like oh is
that right I check in to see like where
they're at and what's going on and it's
like way worse so you're fighting this
constantly yeah
you know there is a medication that
you're taking yeah how tall
I bet you there's another medication
you're taking too looking at your knees
yeah well what are you taking uh I just
smoked some Crystal
yeah that'll do it had some coffee this
morning that'll do it too yeah
Skid Row for how long uh I've been on
Skid Row for like a week now
yeah I just I was at a program when I
got out of prison
um I just got out in November
and I've been in the program the whole
time but they kicked me up for smoking
weed
it was the second time I got in trouble
with drugs there so it was a rehab
program you can't have any alcohol no
drugs you can only smoke cigarettes and
drink coffee so now you're on the street
now I'm on the street
and I [__] off my job interview that I
had going on so I'm not getting that I
might I might start work next week which
would be good it'll be like 100 a day so
that's like that can get me off the
street or getting at least with a good
tent
I want to go to Santa Monica
because that's what I'm more familiar
with I'll safer probably
yeah a little bit safer Venice is pretty
rough though
like I've seen people get their ass beat
for Menace for no reason yeah we get
people murdered here every every day
yeah yeah
and you think this is all because of
your schizophrenia yeah uh
yeah
I think it's like
if it's not real then
it's one hell of a good like
hallucinations because to you it's 100
I've done acid a bunch of times and I've
hallucinated more on pure schizophrenia
like sober schizophrenia than I ever
done on LSD really ever
I saw the moon get sucked into a black
hole
you know how terrifying that is
you're just standing there you look up
and the moon just goes and it's gone
and then you know that Earth is next
yeah
apparently we're in a realm called
Ninjago which means like we were sucked
up by a black hole and we are
California's like the last of the earth
that's left and it's orbiting this black
hole and there's other Ninjago Realms
that have been sucked into the black
hole too and they orbited too and we can
hear them on like the sound of cars that
they can like send clicking noises over
here like you do like this and you'll
like pause it click where somebody is
with nothing because it you know what I
mean just random noises
but there seems to be like always a
pattern and a method to what's going on
with the random noises they all
orchestrate together
and has the crystal Matthews uh
increased or accelerated okay when I was
first in psychosis before I got put on
medication two three years ago two years
ago about three years ago was when I
went into psychosis and I was in
psychosis for a year and I wound up
walking all over I went from Las Vegas I
took a bus through La up through
California into Sacramento where I had
some friends that were staying with I
was staying with and uh the voices were
like they're cannibals they're trying to
sell you for ten ten thousand dollars
get the [__] out of here so I'm like oh
[__] I gotta go so I just left and just
split up my friends you can't override
these thoughts knowing that there's just
news no I have to like I have to believe
it I have to acknowledge all of the
[__] that they're throwing at me
while still simultaneously saying nope
I'm ignoring you
and that's how I make it to from point A
to point B otherwise I would just be
walking reading the ground all the time
doing these weird dances and [__] it's
gonna be hard for you to have a job uh I
can focus
like I just I earned a little money
today helping somebody wash their car
I only got stuck a couple times
and the job that I have applied for that
I'm waiting to hear back on it was just
picking up trash
with Caltrans you can do that yeah
I wouldn't put me in charge of anything
like
that has a lot of responsibility right
right yeah I mean there's nothing you
could have done to avoid this no it just
kicked off out of nowhere like see okay
you were hold uh 29 29 29 when it all
started which is a little bit late for
schizophrenia which is very late for
schizophrenia
uh I've even seen on some doctors show
they're like schizophrenia doesn't just
pop up when you're older I guess it does
and again no drugs no drugs that was
sober I was just saying we didn't have
yeah I was just smoking weed at the time
and all of a sudden I'm like getting
horrific images of my brother being
fillet alive and maybe there was
something in the weed uh maybe it's the
same dude I always get from we always
smoke together so like he wasn't
tripping out right you know I just
was playing Uno with some kids next
thing I know I had to get out of there
maybe we can do it yeah uh well the best
way I've heard it explained is like if
you do a lot of hardcore drugs like
crystal heroin LSD ecstasy Molly stuff
like that uh your
your brain chemical balance has like a
pull that fills up with schizophrenia
like this pool fills up and eventually
you'll get to the top and whenever it
just spills over it's the psychosis and
uh I used to slam Crystal years ago uh
before your schizophrenia yeah
performance schizophrenia I've been
sober for like a year and a half when I
went to psychosis
interesting and uh and like six months
into my psychosis I relapsed again
started slamming started smoking
uh
I okay before when I was when I was in
psychosis before when I started smoking
meth the voices got violent and loud and
like bad before when it was just weed
and tobacco they were like I was
building a boat I was trying to
communicate with this girl in San
Francisco I could see San Francisco from
across the bay the whole time so I'm
like building a boat I'm gonna go see
her and then uh
one day I decided you know what I
deserve to do some Crystal it's been
like two years almost I deserve to do
something and I did a shot and that's
that's when I went [__] it just all
went bad
like the voices became violent like
people raping people and killing them in
houses and [__] and I couldn't do
anything about it how old were you then
29.
maybe 30. so you're saying you you
weren't doing harder drugs I did harder
drugs when I was like 25 26 and then I
quit
for like a year and a half two years and
then when I was like 29
so I did it for like I did it for a year
so I guess it was like 27 when I was
doing hard drugs so 26 27 something like
that and I did it for a year and a half
year year and a half then I quit for a
year and a half to two years
and then and then I relapsed in my
psychosis this time so you had your
schizophrenic episode or whatever and
then you started using Crystal again yes
I see yeah and it made it so much worse
it made it worse yeah when it was just
weed and tobacco the voices were like go
find your family go find something to
eat we're gonna direct you to the next
meal and the neighborhood voices would
walk me to the next meal they woke me to
the hospital one time when I I had sex
in an alley with some chick and got
gonorrhea and my testicle was this big I
couldn't even walk it was huge and uh
you're gonna have to cut this part out
and uh I typically don't
so I I'm like I'm like okay I'm at the
beach I'm like okay I gotta go to the
hospital I can't walk anywhere I can't
even get to the water fountain I I fly
some dude down like hey can I use your
phone but the voices are very adamant
that I don't use technology that I don't
even touch technology
like because apparently I've got like
different magic built up in me and when
I touch stuff it transfers to it and if
I touch technology then I'll put magic
and technology and destroy it
you seem perfectly sensible except
you're saying ridiculous crazy things
right right right are you what's the
craziest thing you've
concocted your imagination or your
schizophrenia
the craziest thing that's concocted
you've already mentioned a few that are
probably that of God
yeah that's probably the craziest one
but apparently God and the devil are the
same Incarnation just a different
lifetimes depending on how much the
people the the the the people are
actually the psychics this is the main
Collective psychic group they control
who is who what numbers you get issued
what what names you'll get issued stuff
like that and they're like you're god
dude you're obviously God every time I
go to the beach if I don't they when I
look at nature if I'm walking on the
street if I look at nature the message
is very clear throw them in the ocean
just throw them in the ocean and then
when I go to the ocean they're like your
God you have to do these things and
you'll have magic and you'll get food
and you'll have everything you want but
you're gonna have to be homeless because
you're also the devil
yeah
when it when my psychosis started it was
kind of interesting it was just me in a
tent in Sacramento hearing Will Smith's
voice outside of my tent explaining to
me that one of us is Jesus and one of us
is the devil and we had to figure out
which one was which and I was like
obviously will you're you're God right
he's like oh well then you're the devil
and that means you inherit the earth and
all the magic that comes with it since
we're going into this magical realm and
uh you'll be able to hear hear things
and see things that nobody else can
believe if only if it wasn't for the
fact that they can all see out of your
left or right eye depending on what kind
of like if they're uh
uh uh an r or a woo
which I know doesn't make any sense but
I know what they're they're distinct
peoples from other dimensions one
focuses on technology and the wool focus
on Magic and we get sucked into
uh a woo black hole which puts us in the
magical realm and the Illuminati is
still trying to use magic so they're
preventing or they're still trying to
use technology so they're trying to
prevent me from going back with the woo
so I can bring magic back more
prominently in the world
yeah despite what you're going through
you seem pretty upbeat and you don't
seem depressed or well hi that helps oh
you're high yeah
but do you get depressed over this
not really uh sometimes like some bad
things will happen like there was a girl
I was talking to in uh San Francisco
apparently she got raped and killed by
like 10 dudes and then they hit her body
in the subway station
and uh this is when I was across the bay
trying to get to San Francisco
and when they did that I just started
writing sort of like spray painting cars
and smashing windows and stuff and like
talking [__] it was like one of the few
times you you might have actually seen
me talking to myself out loud because
most of the time I'm psychic or I can
just like answer using these colored
lights that I can see floating around in
control by doing like this uh
I can give answers to other psychics
depending on what they see
and stuff like that through my eyes I've
heard so many of these stories now and
it seems the mental health issues can
bring on the drug use and the drug use
makes the mental health dual diagnosis
they just make each other worse yeah
what are some of the craziest things
you've
experience with your schizophrenia oh
well when I was on my way from
Sacramento to
Port Richmond
which is right across the paper from San
Fran uh
about halfway there I was like the whole
time I was walking from
Sacramento to the coast I was hearing
psychics talk the whole time you walked
from Sacramento Sacramento to San
Francisco yeah
and I was hearing psychics the whole
time and then about halfway through
there I started saying these symbols
like up here like black orbs just
appearing in front of me and like
knocking stuff over or like moving tree
branches [__] like that like they had
Mass they were moving stuff
and uh
oh anyways
uh
a voice came into my head and it just
dominated the rest of it was like choose
an eye so immediately I shut my left eye
and I closed my left hand I don't know
why I still don't know why
I just know that like
each finger is assigned to
types of people
and
by which finger I use open or closed
will determine which like who can access
my mind or my field of vision at that
time based on how their hand is
positioned
so if even if they're like on another
like in another dimension or under
Another Universe like another reality
there's a me doing this right now
and uh I've walked the rest of the way
from Sacramento to Port Richmond with my
left eye shut and my left hand shot and
I was eating cigarettes the whole time
was eating like I would I would get
Tobacco off the ground and like roaches
that I found people's weed roaches and
I'd roll them up into spliffs and smoke
them and I would go Sims for people so
they wouldn't snitch on me to the
Illuminati on where I was because I had
to deal with the Illuminati that I was
going to let them turn my skin into a
Bible no wonder you had to walk no one's
going to pick up a hitchhiker like you
right
yeah
I wasn't even trying to get in cars I
tried to stay off the road as much as I
could
I walk through like woods and Fields how
long does it take to walk from
Sacramento to San Francisco uh about a
week
about five days it's probably a bus that
would do it in a couple hours probably I
left all my money in Sacramento though I
thought it was the apocalypse I met this
guy who told me he was death
it's like he told me technically he was
dead I was like oh that makes sense
it's like so don't let me touch you and
the whole time he wouldn't touch me
and uh
so for the next three months I tried to
build a boat in Port Richmond with my
left eye shut and my left hand shut and
I was saving up fire magic in my hand
so that one night when I opened my
fingers like this I saw a red spark
between my fingers I closed it again and
my left eye was like a camera that the
Anunnaki could see out of
and uh the other psychics could see out
of probably like in an Illuminati the
Illuminati operated based on lies that's
how their magic works like they don't
use real Ninjago which is like creating
a sound out of nothing
they use radios like and they'll try and
time like horn honking to mean yes or no
depending on where it is so that's why
you were distracted by the horn yeah
yeah
it was basically a warning like if you
talk about this we're going to kill you
that was a message yeah wow yeah
if I heard a hunk at just the right time
I mean if I talk about this they're
going to kill me but whatever
I'm not really worried about them
killing me so when you're sharing these
stories about the Illuminati and all
these other crazy things yeah do you
understand that they're kind of crazy or
do you or do you believe them I don't
know I like to think that it's just
crazy [__] that it's just schizophrenia
there's nothing I can really do about it
but then sometimes something will happen
like somebody will just pop up and say
one word at just the right time that
means that it's all real
and then what I'm hearing like or like
uh
uh I'll be standing next to somebody and
I'll hear a voice on the Wind of this
woman I talk to From Another Dimension
it's like my soul mate but we live on
different worlds so we have to keep
dying and trying to come back on the
same world just so we can be together
and I will hear her on the win
especially when I'm like eating or
smoking weed because in this universe
she's weed basically
and when I eat it I'm eating her when I
smoke and I'm burning her so it's always
bad but the high is like my favorite
High
I prefer weed over a crystal any day
if one of your high school friends who
knew you they wouldn't recognize me they
wouldn't recognize you no I've I have
sent I used to be clean shaven short
hair no but you the way you're speaking
is like oh they would notice me they
would be like what the [__] are you even
talking about though right that's what
I'm saying yeah because you were
sensible back then yeah you never had
bouts of this kind of stuff no I seen
like a couple ghosts one time but I was
like that's a ghost whatever
yeah
but now that I look back on it like that
could have been a precursor for
schizophrenia right yeah
I see some weird stuff sometimes but I
never attributed it like I always
attributed it to drugs or sleep
deprivation because I've always
experimented with sleep deprivation even
since I was a little kid I would just
stay up for days on end drinking like
coffee or eating and working out stuff
like that
I would just try to stay up for as long
as I could the longest I ever made it
was eight days eight days I was like 13.
this is before I ever started using
Crystal right
right I was just uh
I stayed up for eight days and on the
eighth day I passed out in the computer
chair
just having a weird hallucination about
a Jaguar coming up out of the screen
and then I woke up I was like that was
weird my girlfriend has hung up on me
I was talking to her on MSN Messenger
remember that yeah
that's how old I am sure
it's got to be very difficult for you uh
yeah it's kind of a pain to be honest
I've only I'm still getting used to it
like for a while my my psychosis went
away I think it was the stress game and
put it back on the street like
for a while I wasn't hearing voices in
the in the cars driving by I wasn't
hearing like when you had housing yeah
yeah when I was at the program so a
little better lifestyle might be yeah
and the whole time I was in prison I
only hallucinated one time when I smoked
some spice
yes I mean just the whole
homeless lifestyle schizophrenia yeah
yeah for the year that I was on the
street before uh 2020 to 2021
I um I didn't really notice how bad
being homeless was because I was crazy I
was totally out of my mind I was doing
like nonsense [__] if I explained it to
you you just be like oh that's like all
these people that we see on the street
that are just out of their minds yeah I
was one of those they're basically
schizophrenic and probably using meth or
yeah
probably PCP I've never tried PCP that I
don't want to though I've seen people on
PCP it's it's not for me it ain't gonna
help you no
I want to try acid again now that I have
schizophrenia and see what the acid does
to the voices because every drug that I
do has a different effect on the voices
maybe
Ayahuasca uh maybe yeah Ayahuasca that
might be helpful I don't think I don't
think anything else that's on my list of
drugs to try DMT and Ayahuasca are on
the list of things I want to try
I've done acid I would definitely do it
again
I'd recommend it to anybody
how consistent are you with your
medication that you're taking
prescription oh I take it twice a day
every day you do yeah so you're good
about that yeah if you weren't taking it
I don't know uh so when I was in the
program for like five days I didn't have
my meds and on the last day I was in the
I was in the shower and I was cleaning
myself and I started hearing voices on
the outside of the shower I was like
[__] that I want to talk to the lady
immediately hey I need my meds tomorrow
like tomorrow tomorrow and they hooked
it up now I gotta go down to Central
City and see if they'll do refills for
me
your family uh all in Mississippi or
Missouri or Florida they they're aware
of your situation yeah they I went
missing for a year and a half I was on
they had a missing person's report and
everything
because I just I left my phone and my
debit card my ID and my vape and
everything in a gas station parking lot
in Sacramento and just started walking
out of the town you just zoned out just
[__] following voices and
hallucinations walked from Sacramento to
Port Richmond which is right across the
bay from San Francisco and then I spent
three months in Port Richmond and then I
went to San Francisco for three months
and then I walked from San Francisco to
Long Beach so you're one of those crazy
people yes but right now you seem pretty
sensible uh yes I'm ignoring it I can
still hear it in the background I just
can't hear what I can't make out what
they're saying because I'm not listening
to it which I'll deal with later they'll
be like you miss the consequence and sit
like this don't smoke a cigarette not
eat the tobacco no spit on the ground no
like well I can I can assure you that
using crystal meth and staying up how
many days have you gone without sleep oh
I slept last night you did yeah but
typically
uh I have a three-day rule normally you
try to get sleep every three days yeah
yeah if I went without three days I
don't I don't use anything and if I went
three days without sleep I'd be yeah I'd
be a mess yeah well the speed helps
that's like
it's a different High than cocaine
cocaine lasts for like a little bit
and it gets you a little um uh amped up
but
Crystal and like like I don't know how
crack is I've tried it one time I I
didn't see I saw the I kind of saw the
appeal because like when you smoke crack
you get the same Rush feeling as when
you slam Crystal but it lasts for like
that much it'll only lasts a few minutes
whereas when you slam Crystal it lasts
for like 20 minutes you're rushing if
you do a good shot you can't catch your
breath you're trying not to come on
yourself like
you just everything looks amazing
and uh Everything feels like sex
yeah and that lasts for like 20 minutes
10 20 minutes that's crystal meth yeah
whereas with crack you get the same rush
for like five ten minutes
maybe then you need another one and then
you need another one right with Crystal
you get that rush for a little bit and
then you're high as [__] for days you
don't need to do anymore you're gonna be
hot you're gonna be up one shot will
keep you up for two days oh really yeah
if you do it right if you do like a 35
or a 40 you do like a serious shot it'll
keep you up for like two days and then
sexually it does what uh uh put your sex
drive into like Overdrive
I've heard stories uh yeah yeah people
do some crazy [__] on on crystal
everything crazy yeah
like if you get I keep getting
approached by men I think it's the long
hair
well I think I think what do they call a
crystal meth in prison they call it uh
queer juice oh is that what it is
because it turns a straight guy game
yeah
what's your biggest fear now
oh so slipping all the way back into
psychosis
like I was before right you're not that
far away from it right uh I'm still
wearing shoes that's a good sign usually
I take my because I got markings on my
legs like tattoos of symbols and [__]
and then like power symbols and uh which
foot I have on the ground will dictate
how the voices react and what they say
and [__] like that when I was on the
beach I used to draw because I got truth
on my left leg like the yin yang sign is
it tattoo yeah yeah I used to drag my
left leg from the city all the way to
the ocean to snitch on the people like
what they were doing in the city to the
whole world and then everybody would
start yelling over the ocean and sucking
us into another black hole uh by sending
their like their woo magic to us it
would suck us in a black hole and it
would like make the people in the city
if they wanted to survive they had to
start ritual sacrificing each other and
eating each other
and they would leave food out for us and
these would be like human beef patties
you know what I mean
when you eat them and you get more Magic
by eating the people
this talk is an interesting glimpse into
all those crazies that we see on the
streets yeah yeah you just figure
they're all just a bunch of crazy drug
addicts now there's a reason he yelled
at you yeah he had to or that guy was
gonna kill you yeah
and then you end up doing something
illegal yes yeah and possibly violent
too right right they they ruled my
non-violent because nobody got hurt but
uh and they dropped the attempt of
murder because I was trying to save a
little girl and I have schizophrenia and
the judge I got a different judge one
day and he was like this is defense of
another what are you talking about drop
that [__] DA's like fine dismissed my
public defender's like yes I'm getting a
drink tonight and I'm like you need to
calm down we still got five hours to
deal with
you burned somebody's house down uh I
let somebody's house on fire and I
burned a bunch of garbage cans down
how about how much how much damage was
there to the house minimal like yeah
like some smoke damage that's it
the fire didn't even get big
they came outside found the fire pissed
on it and then went back and they were
having a party is all they were doing
they were having a New Year's party
it was like January 1st of 2021 people
in the house yeah they were having a New
Year's party but you in your head there
was a young girl that was being yeah
yeah
so I had to do something
and no one could talk you out of it no
there was nobody around to talk me out
of it but no there were people in the
house
uh they were busy in my mind they were
busy raping her right I see right what a
curse I just I just heard screaming it
was like oh I'm gonna do this now
this is where
huh where did this happen uh Long Beach
Long Beach yeah wow I can't go back
there order
oh you first you poor thing yeah that's
a horrible Affliction yeah it's where
it's it sucks what if I need a bar of
sugar from that guy what am I gonna do
wow
Chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
uh don't get jaded
don't don't take things as blase just
because you've experienced them before
you can probably find new aspects to it
if you look hard enough
excellent Chris thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem I wish you
lots of luck with your schizophrenia
thank you thank you